this program is brought to you by Emory
University revolutions occur when you
change the structure of governance when
the relationship between the ruled and
the ruler has been redefined my heart
wants me to see major change my head
tells me it's probably not going to
happen and the reason for that is I
don't see how you change the structure
the top-down structure in day-to-day
business in governmental operations I
don't know how you change that I don't
know how you take away the power of the
military in Egypt I don't know how you
take away the influence of the Muslim
Brotherhood the question is what do you
do after the election that enables
people to see that there's a real change
I mean after Mubarak are you going to
have Mubarak plus one would be another
autocratic leader and he'll just maybe
make it a lot easier for the people to
participate but will their lives really
change on a daily basis so we have to be
engaged without being in positional we
have two assists without being
domineering we want to provide guidance
without being imperialistic and so
there's a very fine line that you want
to apply and each country it's a little
bit different it makes it difficult for
people in the region to understand that
this consistency in American foreign
policy they would like to see that
you're going to yes use force no use
force yes use new ones known to use new
ones the Saudis for example feel that
the United States pulled the plug out
pulled the rug out from underneath
Mubarak how could you how could you
endorse this guy be is supporter for 30
years and now all of a sudden you're
just letting him go to the winds what
had you know the Saudis of course have
been a close friend in the United States
for many many years and they're
wondering is the United States really
trustworthy is the United States really
going to be there if we need them and so
you have to bend over backwards now to
turn to the Saudi say oh that's okay
we'll be there don't worry we're not
going to you know we're not running from
you I don't see something as exuberant
as we thought they were back in December
when the Tunisian vegetable merchant put
set himself on fire and that's why I
turned
one of the major news networks and I
said before you call these revolutions
let's see what really happens in the
meantime let's call them upheavals the
preceding program is copyrighted by
emory university